all right there have been major
developments with the most popular
picture ever from my Instagram account
this week I will get to that in a second
of course I'm on instagram at David
Pakman you can follow me there first and
foremost I mentioned on a recent
audience question that one of the things
I would like to get better at is drawing
that drawing and painting I just have
never been even remotely skilled at and
well skill talent I don't know which it
is but I'm lacking both and I actually
got a basic learn drawing concepts book
and I posted to Instagram a few days ago
this drawing which it's okay in my
opinion immediately people were saying
oh you know David you got it you got to
do this you got to do that but my
opinion Pat and we can keep this up this
up as we discuss it is that this is okay
for for someone who is terrible at
drawing right I mean my shading is okay
I don't know you know I like it I think
it really speaks to me it just makes me
think that even when you're on top of
that pedestal there your yellow slippery
slope away from falling back into
obscurity so I think it's some deep art
I'm proud of you for it I think that the
biggest area of opportunity is even for
light shading I kind of pushed down too
hard with my pencil and so I'm not
getting the contrast that I need we this
for people who are listening check it
out at David Pakman it's some stacked
three-dimensional sort of blocks ramps
and cubes as I would describe it that
scribble in the top right corner I think
it really brings the piece together
that's the light source in other words
that's sort of where the imaginary light
source is around which the shadow is
based yep that's what that is anyway I'm
enjoying it and I guess I'm kind of
getting better okay so so that's what's
going on number one number two this
picture that we are now going to put up
for you is the most liked picture ever
from my Instagram account and it is a
picture of what happens to my hair if I
do not use product in it to control it
and it is would you call this an afro of
sorts yeah I would call that an afro it
is it was shocking to many people this
is the most liked picture ever on my
Instagram account
and I know that it's it's a disturbing
image to many people but some people
liked it and if you were listening you
want to see this image on my Instagram
at David Pakman it was suggested Pat
that I do an entire show with this hair
if the patreon fundraiser gets to a
certain point okay so I am willing to do
it if we hit 2,000 patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
will do an entire show in studio with my
hair like that I'll have to figure out
how to get here and out of the studio
without people wondering if I'm out of
my mind
but I'm willing to do it if we get to
2,000 patrons so go to
patreon.com/scishow make your
contributions the great thing is we're
targeting 2,000 patrons so if you can
contribute a dollar it's the same in
terms of this goal as if you contribute
a thousand it's very very democratic and
I like that and also this was
immediately Mima fide a viewer turned
that picture into a meme which says you
may have taken away my youtube revenue
but there's one thing David Pakman
always keeps his pride and it's a
cartoon áfive version of my outrageous
hair so anyway it's happening and if we
get to 2,000 patrons I will do an entire
show with my hair looking like that